c'est avec des engagements qui déçoivent
que les dirigeants des 20 plus grandes
puissances vont désormais rejoindre
glasgow après deux jours de sommet à
rome le g20 qui représente à lui seul
80% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre sa déclaration finale était donc
très attendue concernant le climat notre
envoyé spécial à rome estelle sage c'est
un accord de paris quelque peu
réchauffées qui ressort de ce g20
italien sur le front du climat les
dirigeants sont tombés d'accord pour
contenir la hausse des températures sous
la barre des deux degrés tout en
engageant des efforts supplémentaires
pour la limiter à 1,5 degré un objectif
qui nécessite des actions et des
engagements est significatif de la part
de tous les pays ont jugé elle les
dirigeants un accord qui va donc
légèrement plus loin que l'accord de
paris de 2015 toute la question va
maintenant être de savoir comment quel
moyen les pays vont s'engager pour
atteindre cet objectif les dirigeants ne
sont pas parvenus en revanche à donner à
des dates est clair pour sortir du
charbon ou encore pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone du côté des réactions
elles sont en demi-teinte à l'image de
celle de mario draghi l'hôte de ce
sommet elle s'est tout de même dit fier
des résultats obtenus lors de ce g20
mais il a temporisé ce n'est qu'un début
emmanuel macron a de son côté estimé
qu'il fallait obtenir d'autres efforts
de pays comme la chine ou encore la
russie pour autant ce g20 at il dit il a
permis de recréer de la convergence en
vue de glasgow car c'est désormais sur
la coop 26 que tous les regards vont
être braqués une échéance cruciale donc
sur le front du climat boris johnson à
d'ailleurs averti et si glasgow échoue
tout échoue et c'est donc avec les mains
pas tout à fait vite que les chefs
d'état vont s'envoler vers l'ecosse pour
la coop 26 mai les zones angie a de
défense de l'environnement elles sont
déçues elles ont notamment dénoncé le
manque d'ambition et de vision de ce
communiqué final avec des demi-mesures
plutôt que des actes concrets même
constat pour antonio guterres est ce le
chef le secrétaire général de l'onu qui
a dit quitter ce g20 italien avec des
espoirs déçus